So the first thing that you should do, in
order to minimize network latency, is to minimize the
number of HTTP requests. And a major, major way
to do this, is to avoid page redirects. each
redirect can cause a DNS look-up, TCP connect, and
the sending of the actual HTTP request itself all
over again. HTTPS has even more round trips per
connection. So you're looking at high hundreds of milliseconds
per redirects, as a penalty, at least. If you
have a legitimate need for redirects, for example if
you've moved a resource, that's great, but use a
301 redirect if you can. Lots of browsers will
actually update links then. You also want to illuminate
render blocking resources, like waiting on multiple style sheets
or fonts of the like. Anything that forces the
browser to wait for another HTTP transaction to complete,
before it can render the app, is going to
be much more noticeable on mobile. So, combine and
minify those style sheets kits. This also includes avoiding
blocking rendering by waiting for the download of JavaScript
files. If you can use async or defer on
script to let the content render as soon as
possible. In short, you want to prioritize the network
transactions or whatever you need to render the initial
page full of content. Make sure you're loading images on that first page first,
before ones that may be down in the bottom of the page. Get that first
page on the screen as quickly as possible. You should obsess over the network
page and the developer tools. To make
sure you're loading items in the correct order.